Beginning in 1987, under several different
names including The Justified Ancients of
Mu Mu and The Timelords, Drummond and Cauty
produced a number of hit club music singles,
including “Doctorin’ the Tardis.”
By 1991, as The KLF (Kopyright Liberation
Front), the two were one of Britain’s best-selling
music acts.
Before retiring in 1992, the duo released
a blueprint for producing a hit single, The
Manual (How to Have a Number One the Easy
Way) in 1988, and their guidance also provides
insight into the mindset of the artists:
Firstly, you must be skint [broke] and on
the dole [state benefits].
Anybody with a proper job or tied up with
full time education will not have the time
to devote to see it through . . . If you are
already a musician stop playing your instrument.
Even better, sell the junk . . . .”
Apparently the advice was good, since subsequent
bands, including Edelweiss, The Pipettes and
the Klaxons, all enjoyed success after reading
the book.
Nailed to the Wall
Although they were no longer recording, the
two continued to work together on projects.
By August 1994, they had renamed themselves
the K Foundation and created “Nailed to
the Wall,” which was essentially to be £1
million physically nailed to a pine frame.
Dissatisfied with the reception (or lack thereof)
“Nailed to the Wall” received, Drummond
and Cauty devised a new plan.
After being rejected by the Tate Gallery in
Liverpool, Cauty asked, “Why don’t we
just burn it?”
A question to which Drummond, apparently,
had no better reply than “sure.”
Burning a Million Quid
Preferring a small group, Cauty and Drummond
made their way to the relatively isolated
island of Jura in the Inner Hebrides with
reporter Jim Reid and filmmaker Gimpo (aka
Alan Goodrick), on August 22, 1994.
Before leaving London, the group had to get
the £1 million.
Since you can’t just withdraw it from an
ATM and no bank keeps that much handy in small
bills, Drummond and Cauty had hired a security
company, named Ratedale, to arrange the money.
Driving to an industrial area near Gatwick
airport, Cauty and Drummond entered a warehouse
and come out a few minutes later with two
security guards carrying suitcases.
The troop then drove south to the Redhill
Aerodrome where they caught a plane to the
islands.
Staying in a hotel in Jura, the party went
to check on the burn site earlier in the evening,
an old boathouse Drummond and Cauty had previously
used to burn a wicker man on midsummer’s
day 1991.
After returning to the hotel and intending
to going to bed, shortly after midnight on
August 23, 1994, Cauty and Drummond changed
their minds and the group returned to the
boathouse:
Gimpo drags a piece of scaffolding [into the
boathouse with] two triangular bits of cloth
attached near the top of the pole . . . . To
these Gimpo adds two survival flares . . . . Below
the two triangular cloths Cauty is tying a
large piece of aluminum . . . survival blanket.
. . . The pole is hoisted up to the [wooden]
drum which is laid on its side and the lights
and flags flutter and blink over the stormy
night.
Inside the boathouse Drummond is tying the
two bags on to the ropes.
. . . The bags are untied and opened . . . . Cauty
hands [a bundle of money] to Drummond and
. . . lights them both . . . . Drummond is
standing to the left of the fireplace throwing
fresh bundles in, Cauty is to the right . . . . After
five minutes their actions become mechanical,
almost like it is . . . coal that they are
fueling the fire with.
According to Reid, all the money was destroyed
after about two hours.
The Aftermath
Although Cauty had attempted to destroy all
photographic and video evidence of the burning,
Gimpo retained a copy and produced the film
Watch the K Foundation Burn a Million Quid,
which was taken on a screening tour the next
year.
Friends later reported that Drummond and Cauty
were “haunted” by the burning.
Although in 2000 Drummond claimed he did not
rue burning the money, by 2004 he noted: “Of
course I regret it – who wouldn’t!
My children especially regret it, but I don’t
regret it all the time.”
Why?
Early on, Drummond told Reid that they had
nothing better to do with the cash and “needed
to express something about money and we wanted
to push it through art.”
In 2000, Drummond said that the act “wasn’t
about burning all the money . . . [or] cleansing
anyone’s soul.
. . . I’m trying to make sense of something
. . . . I don’t know what it is.
. . . What I will say is that I’ve never
seen it as a destructive thing.
It wasn’t to destroy the money.
It was to watch it burn.”
In 2004, Drummond elaborated: “After a while,
we realized that whatever answer we came up
with would not be good enough . . . . It’s
for other people to explore.”